- I think that girl's into you.
- That super duper pretty
girl with the brown hair?
No way, man.
- So he really likes you.
- Psh. No. I don't know.
(smooth bass music)
(hoots)
- [Man] I think she's into you.
- No, I don't think she's
even looking at me, man.
She's looking right through me
at that hunk of a guy over there.
- He really likes you.
- Oh, no. We're not each other's type.
- A guy like me? No way, man.
She's too classy.
- Who wants perfection, ya know?
- Yeah, don't do it. Don't go over there.
- You're probably right, it's
always better to play it safe.
- You know what? I'm gonna go over there.
- I'm gonna go over there.
- [Both] Hi.
(both laugh)
My friend thinks that--
Whoa. This is weird.
How do we stop this?
Umbrella. Cucumber.
A dog with rakes for hands. Whoa.
I just wanted to ask for your number.
Sure. Really? Cool!
Well, at least this won't be the same.
531-562-
4224, whoa!
(energetic rock music)
- Nine! I'm sorry, 4229.
But everything else was the same.
- [Both] Finally, we're--
(both groan)
(energetic rock music)
My mom's name is Cheryl.
What? Your mom's name is Cheryl?
Whoa! Is anyone getting all this?